[Applaudissements]
j'aime mon métier mon métier c'est
d'être coaché gilles c'est un nouveau
métier
un nouveau métier qui consiste à
accompagner des équipes à faire trois
choses la première c'est délivrer de la
valeur
en gros comment est ce qu'ensemble on va
pouvoir délivrer des services ou des
produits à forte valeur ajoutée pas
délivrer des produits à forte valeur
ajoutée n'importe comment non de manière
performante avec la qualité nécessaire
et surtout toujours en préservant le
bien-être de chacun des membres de
l'équipe
et comme cet exercice est relativement
compliqué on travaille énormément en
agilité sur de l'amélioration continue
qu'on appelle aussi des boucle de
feedback pour apprendre aux équipes à
fonctionner de cette manière là au début
je leur expliquer comment elle devait
faire et je me suis vite rendu compte
que je pouvais pas leur apprendre ou
leur montrer comment être agile de
manière descendante
j'ai donc appris la posture de coach et
à partir du moment où j'ai compris ce
qu'était un coach et gilles c'est à dire
une personne qui a pour mission de
mettre en place un cadre un cadre qui a
la particularité d'être sécurisé et bien
j'ai compris que l'âge leur mettait en
place une nouvelle façon d'apprendre
alors je les accompagne les accompagne
maintenant différemment je les
accompagne avec différents outils les
premiers outils que j'ai à ma
disposition sur des techniques de
questionnements des techniques
on va poser des questions ou vers des
questions fermées
j'utilise également énormément de jeu de
jeu entreprises des jeux pour comprendre
des jeux pour apprendre des jeux pour
faire des jeux pour simuler et puis
récemment j'ai découvert un nouvel outil
qui a complètement révolutionné la
pratique de mon approche de coach à
gilles c'est la facilitation graphique
et cette facilitation graphique
quand j'ai compris ce qu'elle pouvait
m'apporter ça m'a allumé toutes les
lumières alors la facilitation graphique
on en voit beaucoup et souvent ça
ressemble à ça des petits dessins des
petits dessins dans lesquelles vous
retrouvez du texte des couleurs des
liens des personnages et quand je fais
ça dans les organisations
souvent ça fait des effets whaou les
gens trouvent ça joli
les gens trouvent que ça synthétise bien
le moment et puis pour ceux qui n'y
étaient pas il se demande à quoi ça sert
c'est un peu fouillis c'est pas clair il
ya beaucoup d'informations bref pourquoi
est ce qu'il ya un tel emballement
pourquoi est ce qu un tel engouement
pour cette discipline de facilitation
graphique alors quand j'ai l'occasion de
de pouvoir rencontrer ses personnages
déjà je leur explique que ce qu'elle
voit est ce que je viens de vous montrer
c'est un usage de la facilitation
graphique parmi parmi d'autres est ce
que je viens de vous montrer c'est ce
qu'on appelle du screaming le streaming
ça consiste à fait en fait à faire un
enregistrement visuel c'est à dire vous
avez une personne qui fait un
compte-rendu généralement de quelqu'un
qui est en train de parler devant une
assistance mais la facilitation
graphique c'est bien plus que ça vous
avez peut-être entendu parler du sketch
note le sketch nothing c'est une
technique cette fois ci plutôt
individuelle qui consiste à faire de la
prise de notes visuel mais uniquement à
titre individuel parmi les autres
villages à la facilitation graphique
j'utilise beaucoup il ya aussi tout ce
qui est la modélisation la modélisation
ça consiste cette fois ci à faire un
résumé visuel une fois qu'on sait
exactement toutes les données qu'on a
envie de structure et qu'on a envie de
modéliser donc on sait où positionner le
texte vous positionner les dessins de
cette pratique à de cet usage là on a
été dérivé un autre qui s'appelle les
modèles ou en anglais les template qui
sont ni plus ni moins que des panneaux
des métaphores qu'on va faire
harley ou chaque composant du dessin
représente une information et on va
inviter l'équipe à discuter là par
exemple la métaphore du bateau ou en
gros toute l'équipe est dans le même
bateau et se dirige vers une île
fantastique qui va représenter ce qui
est l'objectif hausse qui pourrait être
l'objectif
cette équipe va rencontrer des
difficultés qu'on va représenter par des
parts d encre et donc on a une métaphore
pour faire parler les longs et puis le
dernier usage que je suis en train de
deux mètres de pratiquer en ce moment
c'est le parler dessinée qui consiste à
faire une présentation qu'en live à
expliquer quelque chose et à l'illustrer
en même temps tout ça je le mets au
service d'un seul objectif c'est que
quand j'interviens ça puisse générer des
interactions des interactions entre les
personnes et des espaces interactifs
dans les organisations dans les écoles
dans les entreprises y en a déjà un
espace interactif vous avez une loupe
les jeunes plusieurs personnes qui
parlent ça s'appelle une réunion ça
s'appelle un atelier il faut bien se
rendre compte qu'en ce moment même il ya
des millions de personnes qui sont en
train de perdre leur temps dans ses
réunions dans ces ateliers qui sont en
train de souffrir parce qu'on est en
train de leur faire une présentation
powerpoint
raté
parce qu'on est en train de leur main
des de coller des post-it au mur parce
que les des post-it mur ça aide à faire
réfléchir les gens encore raté
parce qu'on aura demandé avant d'arriver
dans l'atelier où dans la réunion de
prendre connaissance d'un compte rendu
très volumineux qui a pris beaucoup de
temps à être écrit et finalités lui par
pas grand monde
encore raté autant d'outils qui sont
extrêmement puissants extrêmement
puissants et qu'ils ont tous été dédiée
quand même à la même chose c'est à dire
qu'à un moment c'est fait pour
comprendre où c'est fait pour se faire
comprendre
personne qui conçoit des powerpoint qui
fait coller des post it ou qui construit
des comptes-rendus a volontairement fait
acte de sabotage faire perdre le temps
aux gens qui sont dans les réunions dans
les ateliers et donc un problème sur
l'utilisation d'outils simples en
rapport à la complexité des messages et
de la complexité des informations qui
sont proposés danse et interactif
pourtant la complexité d'une information
la complexité d'un message ça on sait
faire on sait faire car on a à notre
disposition un outil dédié qui s'appelle
le cerveau et le cerveau est capable de
gérer de maîtrise et une complexité
fantastique une complexité de messages
d'une complexité de langues à travers
tous les canaux qui nous sont proposés
des canaux aux subtils comme le canal
olfactif ou le canal gustatif le canal
tactile le canal visuel évidemment
quelqu'un à l'auditif
et finalement ce que je suis en train de
vous expliquer c'est que parmi tous les
canaux le deuxième canal le plus simple
à utiliser après le canal auditif
c'est le canal visuel et notre cerveau
pour la plupart d'entre nous est très
réceptif à ça et la facilitation
graphique est tellement développé que
cette facilitation graphique finalement
on est capable de la faire depuis qu'on
est tout petit
en gros pour pouvoir savoir dessiner ce
savoir faire ce que j en train de faire
enfin le niveau de dessin d'un enfant de
4 5 ans en fait avant ça il n'y a pas
forcément besoin de savoir dessiner
on a déjà besoin de savoir écrire si le
visuel est un langage on à l'umq
donc on va donc avoir besoin d'avoir un
vocabulaire de l'écriture évidemment du
dessin la plupart des gens se trouvent
particulièrement complexé par rapport à
leurs niveaux de dessin le niveau de
dessin requis est relativement simple
prenez des formes de base des points des
traits d arc à partir desquels vous
allez pouvoir décliner des formes des
pictogrammes qui vont pouvoir
représenter des objets certains vont
représenter des symboles et vous aurez
peut-être aussi besoin d'animer un petit
peu tout ça notamment en rajoutant des
personnages et qu'on va pas se mentir
effectivement dessinée personnage c'est
ce qui est plus compliqué et si jamais
vous êtes perdus avec vos personnages
deviennent est toujours le bonhomme
patate
le bonhomme patate c'est pratique et
c'est facile à faire
vous avez du vocabulaire et dans un
langage une fois qu'on a du vocabulaire
il va nous falloir un petit peu de
grammaire on va avoir besoin donc de
structurer cette information et la
structuration de l'information de
manière visuelle c'est relativement
simple
on a besoin de traits de flèche on va
pouvoir connecter les informations entre
elles les positionner donc donner du
relief à l'information au dessus ou en
dessous les positionner sur la plage sur
la page d'une certaine manière et si
véritablement des informations sont
connectées entre elles
eh bien on va pouvoir montrer ses liens
la structuration de l'information
visuellement peut s'arrêter en tout cas
démarré avec ce type d'outil une fois
qu'on a du vocabulaire une fois qu'on a
de la grammaire on va pouvoir
on va pouvoir écouter on va pouvoir
raconter écoutez quoi raconter quoi des
histoires l'être humain adore se
raconter des histoires
les histoires ont cette particularité
d'avoir un début une fin et surtout
d'être jalonné ses jalons sont autant de
marqueurs visuel qui vont vous aider à
mémoriser
l'information est à cette époque on peut
se demander si on est encore en capacité
d écoute
quels sont les bénéfices que vous pouvez
attendre de la facilitation graphique
quand vous allez pouvoir la mettre en
oeuvre
ce que j'observe et ce qu'on voit
beaucoup c'est déjà la récupération de
la tension de plus en plus de personnes
sont connectées ultra-connectés les
systèmes de notification nous
envahissent partout récupérer
l'attention des personnes est un enjeu
fort quand on cherche à communiquer et à
transmettre de l'information
une fois qu'on a récupéré la tension on
va pouvoir développer les temps de
réflexion à partir du moment où on a une
ou plusieurs personnes qui commencent à
réfléchir
on va pouvoir aussi développer la
participation
la participation qui va passer par de la
prise de parole des questions des
objections
et au final finalement de la
mémorisation
voilà les bénéfices qu'on peut attendre
et qu'on observe aujourd'hui en
facilitation graphique
alors si vous aussi vous avez envie vous
avez envie de donner envie de
transmettre si vous voulez donner envie
de communiquer si vous voulez donner
envie d'apprendre si vous voulez donner
envie de comprendre et de faire
comprendre
je vous lance une invitation tout le
monde en est capable alors allez-y
prenez le crayon je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]